[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
willkommen Norbert Lehmann ist auch
dabei für den Sport
500 Tage Krieg Präsident silenski
beschwört den Durchhaltewillen doch im
Militär herrscht großer Mangel
Sonne Sommerhitze Deutschland sucht
Abkühlung aber den Schwimmbädern fehlte
sein Bademeister
und Spektakel für spektakulären Sport
bei den Finals werden in Dutzenden
Sportarten deutsche Meister gekürt
es ist ein düsterer Meilenstein seit 500
Tagen herrscht Krieg im Zentrum Europas
seit 500 Tagen wären sich die Ukraine
und Ukraine Rinnen gegen den russischen
Angriff zu einem immer höheren Preis zu
Kriegsbeginn hatte Russland schnell
Geländegewinne gemacht und war im Norden
fast bis zur ukrainischen Hauptstadt
Kiel vorgedrungen nach massiver
Gegenwehr zogen sich die russischen
Truppen erst in den Südosten und den
Süden und dann auf die Ostseite des
Flusses niebrot zurück seither tobt an
der Frontlinie ein Kampf um jeden Meter
Jürgen kill
500 Tage Krieg 500 Tage Krieg der Bilder
heute veröffentlichte Aufnahmen
Präsident selensky auf der von den
Russen zurückeroberten Schlangeninsel er
ehrt seine Kämpfer beschwört die eigene
Stärke
Ruhm der Ukraine an der Front bei
bachmut melden die Ukrainer kleinere
Erfolge selbst entwickelte bodana
Artilleriegeschütze verschießen NATO
Munition doch die wird offenbar langsam
knapp
ich habe heute gelesen dass US-Präsident
beiden bestätigt hat dass er uns Streu
Munition liefert das wird total cool
dann müssen wir viel weniger Granaten
verschießen man trifft eine ganze Fläche
jetzt treffen wir nur einzelne Punkte
Streubomben explodieren oft erst lange
nach ihrem Abwurf eine Gefahr auch für
Zivilisten viele Staaten haben Sie
deshalb geächtet russland zeigt sich
empört nutzt die Waffen aber wohl auch
selbst in der Ukraine am 500sten
Kriegstag Bilder des russischen
Verteidigungsministers Show beim
Training seiner Panzertruppen in
Russland
machen die Fehler nicht mehr die sehen
im letzten Jahr noch gemacht haben sie
haben dazu gelernt sie haben sich gut
vorbereitet sie haben organisiert und
sie haben jetzt erhebliche Ressourcen im
Einsatz die stärker sind als das was sie
zu Beginn des Krieges in der Ukraine
hatten 500 Tage russischer Angriffskrieg
Ausgang ungewiss sicher ist nur dass die
Zahl der Opfer weiter steigen wird
unsere Porter Dara hassanca die ist
immer wieder in der Ukraine gerade ist
der Ischium Dara wie hat sich die
Stimmung seit Kriegsbeginn verändert ist
da immer noch so viel Mut und so viel
Kampfbereitschaft
ja hier in Issum was letztes Jahr
befreit wurde bei der Offensive im
Nordosten ist die Stadt an am
Samstagabend menschenleer ich habe eben
gerade mit zwei alten Frauen gesprochen
die haben gesagt sie haben ihre Kinder
jetzt seit 500 Tagen nicht gesehen sie
sind bei Kriegsbeginn geflüchtet aus der
Stadt und im Ausland heute Mittag an der
Freund in der Nähe von bachmut habe ich
mit einem Militär Arzt gesprochen er
sagte der Krieg hat uns alle verändert
vielleicht für immer aber die
Unterstützung der Bevölkerung spüre er
hier im Militär nach wie vor sie kommt
in Form von von
humanitären Hilfsmitteln aber auch von
von Zeichnungen von Kindern und der
Wille sei ungebrochen denn die Ukraine
haben in den letzten 500 Tagen erfahren
was ein Leben unter dem Joch Russlands
und einer Eroberung bedeuten würde
Sarah Hassan danke schön für diese
Einschätzung
in die Niederlande dort ist die
Regierungskoalition nach nur 18 Monaten
auseinander gebrochen zu groß waren die
Differenzen in der Migrationspolitik
innerhalb des viererbündnisses
Ministerpräsident rütte trat zurück er
und seine rechtsliberale Partei wollten
unter anderem den Familiennachzug von
Flüchtlingen beschränken doch zwei der
Koalitionspartner die linksliberalen und
die Christen Union sperren sich dagegen
Isabel Schäfers
im Fenster dieser Amsterdamer
Buchhandlung werden eigentlich Bücher
von Verstorbenen Autoren ausgestellt
heute wird hier mit einem Augenzwinkern
der gescheiterten Regierung gedacht
gestern Abend hatte premier rütte
bekannt gegeben dass die Koalition an
der Asylpolitik zerbrochen ist
das Problem sehen wir alle und auch dass
wir Lösungen finden müssen aber nach
langen und intensiven Gesprächen über
mögliche Lösungsansätze müssen wir
feststellen dass uns das nicht gelingt
es sind Bilder wie dieser aus dem
letzten Sommer Bilder von überfüllten
niederländischen Flüchtlingslagern die
margrette künftig vermeiden wollte
deshalb hatte er vorgeschlagen den
Familiennachzug von Asylsuchenden zu
begrenzen diese Verschärfung wollten
nicht alle Koalitionspartner mittragen
wir müssen stattdessen Maßnahmen
ergreifen um Platz für die Menschen zu
schaffen die eine Recht auf unsere
Aufnahme haben eine menschenwürdige
Aufnahme wenn sie aus einem Krieg zu uns
kommen
möglicherweise hat Magritte die schon
länger streitende Koalition nicht nur
wegen des aktuellen Konfliktes scheitern
lassen
dieser Zeitpunkt für den Premier gar
nicht so schlecht um vorgezogene
Neuwahlen abzuhalten dass er sich etwa
für strengere asylvorschriften einsetzt
könnte sich bei der aktuellen Stimmung
im Land positiv bei den Wahlen auswerten
heute fuhren noch premierrütte zum König
um ihn über das Ende der Regierung zu
informieren mit Neuwahlen ist
voraussichtlich im Herbst zu rechnen
zehntausende Tonnen Chemiewaffen
lagerten mal auf der Welt nun gibt es
zumindest offiziell keine mehr
ausgewiesene Bestände hatten zuletzt nur
noch die USA und die haben sie nach
eigenen Angaben jetzt komplett
vernichtet russland hatte diesen Schritt
bereits 2017 bekannt gegeben das Land
steht aber wie andere Staaten auch im
Verdacht weiter nicht deklarierte
chemische Kampfstoffe zu besitzen
die USA und China konkurrieren in vielen
Feldern auch bei künstlicher Intelligenz
da gibt es eine Art digitales Wettrüsten
Peking hat das Ziel deklariert bis 2030
Weltmarktführer zu werden was künstliche
Intelligenz kann und wie sie in China
eingesetzt wird zeigt gerade eine Messe
in Shanghai Elisabeth Schmidt war dort
auf die Messe geht es ohne Ticket aus
Papier einlassper Gesichtserkennung in
den Messehallen Service-Roboter die aus
Kellner oder Mechaniker arbeiten in
China längst Alltag dieser Roboter kann
eine Niere entfernen und Ärzten bei
komplizierten Eingriffen helfen dieser
Roboter hat schon mehr als 1000
Operationen in gut 40 Kliniken in über
20 chinesischen Provinzen durchgeführt
earlybot heißt der chinesische
Konkurrent des amerikanischen Chat GPT
einen Programm das Bilder und Texte
erstellen kann noch spricht Ernie
allerdings nur chinesisch und befindet
sich in der Testphase doch in China
wurden bereits knapp 80 solcher KI
Modelle entwickelt viel Pragmatismus
wenigstens beim Datenschutz
es ist eh nicht zu ändern es geht darum
unser Leben einfacher zu machen
und sehr sicher
allerdings ohne
hochleistungscomputerchips keine
Komplexe KI Chinas Anspannung bekommen
wir als ausländische Presse auf der
Weltkonferenz zu spüren
sensible Technologien wie Chips und
Halbleiter durften wir hier auf der
Messe nicht filmen denn Chips sind
Chinas wunder Punkt noch ist die eigene
Technologie nicht so weit entwickelt und
die USA beschränken die Ausfuhr von
Chips und Halbleitern nach China immer
schärfer mit Milliardensummen will die
Staatsführung KI jetzt weiter
voranbringen
Überwachungstechnologie
militäranwendungen künstliche
Intelligenz soll das Leben der Menschen
leichter machen sie soll in China aber
vor allem einer dienen der
Kommunistischen Partei
angesichts steigender Kosten im
Gesundheitsbereich stellt der
Sozialverband VdK die Zahl der
Krankenkassen in Frage 96 gäbe es in
Deutschland jede habe eine teure
Verwaltung so vdk-chefin Bentele
gegenüber der Funke Mediengruppe gebe es
weniger Kassen ließe sich viel Geld
sparen
wir spüren sie alle eine neue Hitzewelle
hat Deutschland erreicht heute mit bis
zu 35 Grad morgen soll es noch heißer
werden an der Ostsee zog ist Tausende an
den Timmendorfer Strand auch viele
Freibäder erfreuten sich großer
Beliebtheit wie hier in Hannover doch
für viele Schwimmbäder wird dieser
Sommer eine echte Herausforderung denn
es fehlt an Bademeistern Christina
iglseder berichtet
Abkühlung bei der Hitze in diesem
Freibad im Landkreis Hildesheim geht das
nur noch nachmittags die Öffnungszeiten
sind stark eingeschränkt pro Jahr machen
in Deutschland im Schnitt 80 Bäder
gleich ganz dicht die Gründe nicht nur
die Kosten sondern auch Personalmangel
Schwimmmeister hendringen gesucht das
Schreiben aus auch auf verschiedenen
Kanälen ob sie nun social Media ist
presseklassisch oder auch Mundpropaganda
ne das hat halt noch nicht gefruchtet
ein Job in der Sonne mit Schattenseiten
hohe Verantwortung und arbeiten dann
wenn andere frei haben auch am
Wochenende und das bei einem
Einstiegsgehalt von gerade mal 2.200 €
brutto wir müssen ja auch man glaubt es
kaum auch säubern das Bad
es ist ja nicht nur hier gucken zurzeit
fehlen 3000 Schwimmmeister so viel wie
nie auch Rettungsschwimmer die aushelfen
könnten am Schwimmbäder offen zu halten
sind Mangelware während der Pandemie
konnte die DLRG nur halb so viele
ausbilden wie sonst die dramatischen
Folgen die eingeschränkte Öffnungszeiten
mit sich bringen sind natürlich dass
Menschen auf Gewässer ausweichen die
nicht bewacht sind und sich so auch in
Lebensgefahr begeben und natürlich dass
die Kinder nicht mehr unter sicheren
Bedingungen das Schwimmen mehr lernen
können sich sicher über Wasser halten
das kann am Ende der Grundschulzeit
schon jetzt nicht einmal mehr jedes
zweite Kind wie viele seiner Kollegen
geht er bald in Rente ohne eine
Nachfolger könnte es auch hier mit dem
Badespaß dann ganz vorbei sein
es bleibt heiß der Deutsche Wetterdienst
warnt aktuell vor starker Wärmebelastung
im Westen und Südwesten was jeder zu
Hause gegen die hohen Temperaturen tun
kann können Sie in unserer ZDF heute App
nachlesen z.B einen Becher mit
Eiswürfeln vor den Ventilator stellen
in Uruguay in Südamerika sind es heute
maximal 14 Grad dort ist Winter trotzdem
leidet das Land unter einer Dürre der
schlimmsten seit 40 Jahren ebenso lange
hat der Staat versäumt in die
Trinkwasserversorgung zu investieren das
was nun aus wasserhennen kommt ist
salzig sandig und chlorhaltig das
belastet vor allem die Gesundheit von
Kindern Christoph Karat berichtet
vor ihrem Haus am Stadtrand von
Montevideo will ins Victoria zeigen wie
übel das Wasser ist das hier seit Beginn
der Dürre aus der Leitung kommt ihr Sohn
Gustavo aber trinkt es sofort obwohl er
davon wahrscheinlich Bauchschmerzen
bekommen wird
es ist schlecht aber uns bleibt nichts
anderes übrig wenn wir kein anderes
Wasser haben trinken die Kinder dieses
das Leitungswasser wird immer
ungenießbarer seit die Stadt salziges
Wasser einspeist dass sie direkt aus der
meeresmündung des Rio de la Plata
entnimmt ohne würde das Netz
zusammenbrechen
die Region um die Hauptstadt Uruguays
leitet unter der schlimmsten Dürre seit
Jahrzehnten die Stauseen die die Stadt
versorgen sind so gut wie ausgetrocknet
obwohl die Gegend normalerweise sehr
wasserreich ist neben klimatischen
Faktoren machen Wissenschaftler auch die
Agrarpolitik verantworten
diese Krise hat ihren Anfang schon vor
vielen Jahrzehnten genommen als im
Einzugsgebiet der Flüsse die
Landwirtschaft intensiviert wurde das
hat zur Boden die Generation zu Boden
Erosion und dem Verlust der
Wasseraufnahmefähigkeit der Böden
geführt
Trinkwasser gibt es nur noch aus
Flaschen die werden subventioniert doch
für die Ärmsten sind sie trotzdem zu
teuer
und im Stadtpark haben sie Brunnen
gegraben die sauberes Grundwasser nach
oben pumpen um wenigstens die
Krankenhäuser versorgen zu können doch
all das ist keine Lösung auf Dauer
Wissenschaftler sehen in der Situation
von Montevideo eine Lehre für die ganze
Welt gravierende Klimaphänomene kündigen
sich oft lange an doch wenn die Menschen
nicht rechtzeitig reagieren gibt es
keinen schnellen Ausweg selbst wenn es
so wie jetzt gerade zwischendurch mal
kurz regnet die Krise von Montevideo
dürfte noch vier bis fünf Monate
andauern befürchten Experten
in Deutschland wächst langsam die Zahl
der Elektroautos knapp 19% der
Neuzulassungen im ersten Halbjahr waren
Autos mit rein elektrischem Antrieb was
viele noch abschreckt ist die geringe
Reichweite wenn der Akku höchstens 400
Kilometer reicht dann kann die Fahrt in
den Urlaub schon mal zu Herausforderung
werden wie das so klappt Jan Hofer hat
sich auf der Autobahn umgehört
unterwegs auf der A3 Richtung Süden die
meisten e-autofahrer an dieser
Raststätte bei Düsseldorf haben gute
Erfahrungen gesammelt ich komme gerade
aus dem Urlaub unterwegs
gebaut werden dabei hat sich die Lade
Infrastruktur in den vergangenen Jahren
gut entwickelt mittlerweile gibt es in
Deutschland 88
3.300 Ladepunkte doch es gibt ein
Problem für Urlauber die möglichst
schnell laden wollen nur 18 Prozent der
Strom tanken sind sogenannte
schnellladestellen und damit für
Urlauber geeignet meist entlang der
Autobahn in Süd- und Osteuropa ist das
Ladenetz schlechter und ein EU-weit
einheitliches Bezahlsystem gibt es nicht
trotzdem der ADAC hält auch lange
Urlaubsreisen im E-Auto für machbar wenn
man vorbereitet ist mit dem E-Auto in
den Urlaub zu fahren heißt immer auch
die Route gut zu planen und auch
unbekannte Faktoren zu berücksichtigen
Ladesäulen können mal belegt oder oder
kaputt sein deswegen am besten immer
eine Restreichweite von 20% einplanen
und Standorte mit möglichst viel
Ladepunkten anfahren und dann gilt die
so oft man muss sich einfach trauen
bei Ausschreitungen rund um das
umstrittene Eritrea Festival im
hessischen Gießen sind nach
Polizeiangaben 22 Beamte verletzt worden
mindestens 60 Menschen würden am Morgen
vorsorglich in Gewahrsam genommen die
Einsatzkräfte seinen mit Flaschen
Steinen und Rauchbomben angegriffen
worden berichtet die Polizei insgesamt
1.000 beamte hatten verhindert das
Gegner des Militärregimes in Eritrea das
Festivalgelände stürmen die gegen Demo
wurde inzwischen für beendet
Sonne Hitze und elektronische Beats in
Berlins Zentrum geben heute mehr als
100.000 Techno-Fans den Takt vor die
Parade Rave the planet sei eine
friedensstiftende Maßnahme sagen die
Veranstalter allerdings gab es wegen der
großen Hitze und den Menschenmassen
ziemliche bedenken wie es bisher lief
auf den Spuren der legendären Loveparade
Sebastian
der Wettergott scheint definitiv ein
Techno jünger zu sein bei
schweißtreibenden Temperaturen tanzten
über 100.000 Raver zwischen Siegessäule
und Brandenburger Tor beim Loveparade
Nachfolger Rave the planet Retro Gefühle
inklusive
den Anfang der 90
Planet wir waren 2000 schon hier wir
sind jetzt wieder hier Freiheit tanzen
das Leben leben
dabei war bis heute morgen nicht klar ob
die Demo so stattfinden kann der
Sicherheitskonzept wackelte die
zuständigen Behörden gaben im letzten
Moment erst grünes Licht für die Parade
die sicherheitspolitische Demonstration
versteht
die Technokultur hat in der
Vergangenheit die letzten 30 Jahre 35
Jahre bewiesen dass sie diese Kraft
besitzt die Menschen friedlich zu einem
und ich denke daher dass die wichtigste
message das heutigen Tages ist das
Technokultur eine Friedenskultur ist und
das hier ist heute genauso auch als
Friedensdemonstration zu verstehen die
Berliner Polizei rief derweil dazu auf
die Kleidung anzubehalten damit den
Raven die harten Beats und hohen
Temperaturen nicht zu Kopf steigen
ja ehrlich zu den DFB Frauen Norbert ist
die WM-Generalprobe gestern ziemlich
Missgeburt der 2-3 Niederlage gegen
Sambia das ist ja an für sich schon
ärgerlich genug aber dazu kommt ja noch
die schwere Verletzung von Carolin Simon
die starke Münchner Verteidigerin fehlt
im WM Kader 24 Spielerinnen werden sich
ohne sie am Dienstag auf den Weg nach
Australien machen
sportlich und menschlich ist es eine
wahre Tragödie
in der 95 Minute im letzten Testspiel
reist der Münchnerin Carolin Simon das
Kreuzband die 30-Jährige hatte schon die
Europameisterschaft verpasst nun bleibt
ihr auch die WM verwehrt nicht die
einzige Sorge für Bundestrainerin
Martina Forst Tecklenburg denn gestern
Abend tanzten die Stürmerinnen aus
Sambia förmlich durch ihre DFB Abwehr
eine defensive Absicherung war quasi
nicht vorhanden es hagelte gleich drei
runtergehen tot immerhin die deutsche
Offensive macht Hoffnung die zwei späten
Treffer durch leer Schüler und Alexandra
Popp beweisen die exzellente Moral des
Teams in 16 Tagen wird's ernst dann
spielt die elf bei der WM gegen Marokko
dem Wechsel von Mini Kim vom
italienischen meistern Neapel zu Bayern
München steht offenbar nichts mehr
entgegen der 26-Jährige koreanische
Abwehrspieler soll nach übereinstimmende
Medienberichten einen Fünfjahresvertrag
beim FCB bekommen die Ablöse Summe 50
Millionen Euro
zu den Finals den Deutschen
Meisterschaften den 18 Sportarten heute
der Tag der Sprinter im hundert Meter
Lauf siegten so in Gina lippenkämper und
Jannik Wolf ja und schnellster deutscher
Speed Kletterer darf sich Leander
karmanns nennen
ein starker und ausgeglichener Lauf und
das im Rekordzeit von 5,299 Sekunden der
18-Jährige kamans setzt sich gegen den
Vorjahresmeister und Trainingspartner
Linus Bader durch
ihre nächsten deutschen Meistertitel
sichert sich da ja bei fulum in der
Rhythmischen Sportgymnastik nach Gold
gestern im meerkampf gewinnt die Welt
und Europameisterin heute auch mit
Reifen Ball Keulen und Band damit räumt
die 16-jährige alle fünf Einzeltitel in
ihrer Sportart ab
im Geräteturnen freut sich die
rekordmeisterin Elisabeth Seitz über
Gold am stufenbaren dank einer nahezu
perfekten Übung holt die Europameisterin
in einem hochklassig besetzten Finale
bereits ihren 25 nationalen Titel Gold
auch für den Europameister Julian Weber
88 m 72 im dritten Versuch mit Saison
Bestleistung krönt sich der Mainzer zum
dritten Mal in Serie zum deutschen
Meister
[Applaus]
zur Tour de France achte Etappe von
libon nach limosch mit einer besonderen
Herausforderung für die Fahrer kurz vor
dem Ziel denn der schlussspringt der
geht bergauf 5% Steigung auf den letzten
700 Metern Sieger der Dänemarks Petersen
vor dem dreimal den Etappen Sieger
Jasper Philipsen aus Belgien und dessen
Landsmann baut von Art
das war es vom Sport danke schön
das Wetter bringt morgen hohe
Hitzebelastung plus schwere Gewitter
Details hat gleich aus den terli im
heute-journal um Viertel vor elf begrüßt
Sie Christian Sievers und wir sind
morgen wieder da danke Ihnen und Tschüss
und einen schönen Abend noch
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter morgen geht es
schon wieder zur Sache mit einer
unwetterlage allerdings ist es erst
einmal relativ trocken und sonnig der
Reihe nach auf unserem Film sehen wir
hier die letzten Schauer im Südwesten
heute Nacht mehr oder weniger
verschwinden dann morgen im Tagesverlauf
erst am Nachmittag im Westen und dann
später im Nordwesten das sind die
Gewitter Herde die dann stark Regen
bringen teilweise Orkane artige Böden
und größeren Haare das ganze ist morgen
durchaus möglich nach Osten hin ist es
erst einmal trocken und überwiegend
sonnig dass die Übersicht in der Nacht
überwiegend trocken und einige wenige
Wolken im Südwesten ja 10 Grad Richtung
Ostsee ansonsten sehr warm im Westen das
ist mit 21 Grad tatsächlich der
tiefswert in den Frühstunden und morgen
dann am Vormittag einige harmlose morgen
zum Nachmittag eben diese schwer
Gewitter erstmal im Westen und dann im
Nordwesten und wie man hier aussieht
viel Sonnenschein den östlichen Landes
teil dazu eine große Hitzebelastung
schwül heiße Luft bis 38 Grad und die
nächsten Tage gehen weiter mit Schauern
und Gewittern ein schöner Abend